[Applaudissements]
ce soir est une sorte de retour au local
pour moi parce que je suis né ici dans
les hauts-de-seine à quelques centaines
de mètres de là où nous nous trouvons
après je suis parti loin assez longtemps
et me voici de retour devant vous ce
soir pour parler du retour au local et
ce alors ce local pour moi c'est paris
j'ai commencé à travailler sur paris par
le biais de son histoire
j'ai écrit un livre sur l'histoire de
l'urbanisme parisien au pendant la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle et j'ai
commencé à enseigner l'histoire de la
ville de paris spécifiquement ce que je
fais encore mais l'essentiel de mon
activité professionnelle aujourd'hui et
l'avenir de paris je travaille sur des
grands projets d'infrastructures comme
ici le grand paris express dont on voit
le premier tunnelier en train d'être mis
en place à chantepie sur des projets de
nouveaux quartiers ou de bâtiments et se
travaille donc avec un regard east
ancrée dans l'histoire locale mais
focaliser actuellement sur l'avenir m'a
donné quelques enseignements et quelques
convictions
ma première conviction est que nous
sommes en train de changer d'ère urbaine
donc si on regarde du point de vue
historique
nous sommes encore dans une période de
l'histoire urbaine qu'on peut appeler
l'air de la ville industrielle qui a
commencé dans les années 1830 1840 en
angleterre puis s'est étendue à l'europe
et l'ensemble du monde au 20e siècle
c'est une ville qui est caractérisée par
ce que louer ce même fln historiens des
villes appel l'idéologie de la machine
et qui est dominé par des systèmes de
gouvernance est une chose que je
voudrais mettre en exergue qui est un
rapport particulier avec l'environnement
qui ne prend pas du tout en compte les
externalités qui ne perçoit pas la
planète comme un système clos et qui
instaure donc un rapport gagnant perdant
avec la nature ce système est en train
d'arriver à sa fin et nous sommes en
train de rentrer dans une nouvelle aire
urbaine qui sera modelé par des facteurs
environnementaux technologiques sociaux
il ya beaucoup de l'avenir urbain
possible rat des villes très diverses
entre elles mais qui seront à mon avis
fondamentalement différente avec celle
de l'air dont nous sortons et c'est ce
qui rend cette période totalement
fascinante à vivre pour les
professionnels de l'urbain dont je fais
partie ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre une immense discontinuité avec de
très grands défis parce que rien ne
signifie que cette nouvelle période sera
meilleur que la période dont on sorte on
en est sorti et malgré toutes les
promesses qu'elle sera particulièrement
idyllique
je peux vous faire qu'on vous le
catalogue des menace terrifiante qui
pèse sur nous des choses comme le
changement le changement de climat qui
va créer des catastrophes naturelles des
inondations des tempêtes des des
sécheresses des incendies des des sujets
liés aux immigration de masse qui vont
forcément accompagner le changement
climatique nos infrastructures urbaines
qui aujourd'hui sont rendus vulnérables
parce qu'elles sont connectés donc le
risque de cyberterrorisme également des
risques par exemple de totalitarisme
numérique avec la reconnaissance faciale
jeolla été localisée l'exploitation des
données personnelles
je vais continuer là parce que surtout
il ya une chose c'est le risque de
déploiement massif et non maîtrisée de
technologies extrêmement puissante et là
je pense à l'arrivée imminente des
véhicules autonomes
donc nous sommes dans une période
fascinante parce que nous avons des
grandes opportunités des grands risques
on est à une période véritablement
hier où il ya un très large éventail
d'avenir possible ma deuxième conviction
était est autour de du rôle de paris
dans tout ça paris spécifiquement
pendant la deuxième moitié du xixème
siècle était un modèle urbain
c'est à dire que c'était une ville que
les administrateurs municipaux du monde
entier venez visiter ont regardé nos
voiries nos espaces publics nos espaces
verts notre architecture ont visité même
nos égouts pour rentrer chez eux les
gens rentrés chez eux et essayer de
reproduire ce qu'on faisait de bien à
paris aujourd'hui paris n'est plus un
modèle urbain
on est même au niveau mondial plus comme
on l'était à l'époque une des grandes
villes du monde paris est aujourd'hui la
28e agglomération du monde et on perd
des places au classement tous les ans
donc quand on regarde les faits
objectifs on est une ville au niveau des
métropoles mondiales plutôt petit
vieillissante et qui a perdu son
exemplarité
donc la question c'est est ce que nous
sommes du coup condamné à être une sorte
de ville musée une ville sympathique et
pittoresque que les les visiteurs
asiatiques ou américains prendront
plaisir à venir voir et faire des des
photos et venir dans nos hôtels ou
est-ce que nous pouvons continuer à
jouer le rôle de leadership de la pensée
de l'innovation que nous avons assumé à
plusieurs moments de notre histoire et
ma conviction est que nous pouvons
encore le faire tous les défis dont j'ai
parlé nous devons y faire face et les
résoudre principalement pour nous-mêmes
pour avoir un mode un modèle de vie
durable et une qualité de vie une
cohésion sociale dans l'avenir dans
lequel nous projettons mais je pense
également que paris peut continuer à
avoir un rôle d'exemplarité dans ce
nouveau monde qui qui est devant nous
mais il faut que nous rendions bien
compte que c'est un peu à l'encontre de
la tendance historique qu'il faut qu'on
se donne les
moyens de cette ambition est que il faut
qu'on aille chercher ce rôle
d'exemplarité
maintenant le monde vers lequel on va ce
que les uns par à l'impératif de cet
avenir urbain qu'on doit créer s'est
passé assez clair c'est les sujets
autour de l'environnement autour des
sujets dont j'ai parlé c'est pas ça la
partie la plus difficile de l'équation
la partie la plus difficile de la
création c'est le comment et là dans le
coma il ya des choses qui me remplissent
d'espoir et des choses qui ne
remplissent pas du tout d'espoir et dans
le domaine des choses qui me remplissent
pas du tout d'espoir il y a ça c'est que
il y à bien des problèmes qu'on doit
résoudre collectivement en tant que
habitants d'un d'un fait territoriale de
10,7 millions de parisiens qui habitent
ensemble et qui ont un avenir
territoriale partagée
il ya des grandes décisions
d'investissements d'infrastructures ou
de règles sur comment on utilise notre
espace et comment on vit en commun qu'on
doit bien résoudre à cette échelle là et
on a beaucoup de mal à y arriver le bon
sens et qu'il nous faut un maire pour
directement élu par la population pour
cette colle et c'est 2010 7 millions
d'habitants quelqu'un qui puisse
incarner une vision et une stratégie
pour ce territoire pour ce fait
territoriale objectif et il ne faut pas
412 mères différentes comme on l'a
actuellement avec cinq ou six strates
d'administration avec des 10 et des
divisions et des contradictions entre
eux par contre il y arriver est
extrêmement laborieux et cet aspect là
est frustrant et difficile à vivre
tout n'est pas négatif du côté public il
par exemple le grand paris express dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure est un grand
grand investissement
une véritable ambition est quelque chose
qui est un marqueur de là où on veut
aller
on a également d'autres sujets comme
l'environnement où visé
le mans il ya un certain appétit pour
des prises de décisions politiques
courageuses en ce moment même si à paris
on a la fâcheuse tendance de toujours
mettre en avant des objectifs
environnementaux très ambitieux à très
long terme plutôt que d emblée des
objectifs à court terme est beaucoup
plus concret ce qui me remplit d'espoir
c'est le côté de l'engagement citoyen et
la coalition de bonnes volontés
une constellation que je vois de
personnes sur le terrain dans des
associations des entreprises des
individus qui se saisissent concrètement
de tous les sujets urbains qui vont
définir notre avenir est ce qu'ils vont
commencer à modeler l'avenir urbain que
nous pouvons souhaiter alors ça c'est
des choses comme ici un exemple c'est
avec des vtt up qui travaillent ici
c'est à aubervilliers dans une cité
d'aubervilliers est alors en
l'occurrence c'est de créer un potager
mais c'est pas le potager qui est
important c'est que pour la première
fois on aide ces populations cette
population de cette cité en particulier
à s'approprier son espace urbain et donc
c'est de créer une dynamique où les
citoyens de cette zone sont devienne
véritablement engagés dans la
construction de leur avenir
il ya ensuite tous les sujets très
concrets d'amélioration de notre ville
ici c'est aux pages et qui fait des
l'agriculture urbaine sur les toitures
de les toits de paris et de
l'agriculture qui donc qu'ils cultivent
des légumes qui peuvent être utilisés
dans les restaurants parisiens en
circuit court
ce n'est qu'un exemple il ya les gens
qui cultivent les endives et les
champignons dans les sous-sols dash-l m
il y a des gens qui travaillent sur la
biodiversité sur le zéro déchet sur la
ville bas carbone sur l'économie
circulaire sur l'économie de proximité
tous ces sujets là toutes ces dynamiques
sont en dessous cias menthe et sont
importantes mais elles peuvent être
encore plus importante c'est la question
que je me pose c'est toujours comment
peut-on faire pour aider à avoir encore
plus de visibilité encore plus d'ampleur
à ces mouvements citoyens convoi dans la
ville
il faut jamais que
oublions que lorsqu'on travaille sur la
ville ce qu'on fait dépasse le cadre de
nos propres vies c'est un legs napoléon
iii parlait souvent dans ces termes dans
ses discours et je pense qu'ils avaient
raison parce que lorsqu'on voit la ville
concrets comme quelque chose qu'on
transmet sa change fondamentalement le
cadre de réflexion on voit plus les
décisions comme un arbitrage entre un
groupe d'intérêt et un autre groupe
d'intérêt mais comme une décision
structurelle sur ce qui va générer le
meilleur avenir urbain donc adoptons ce
cadre deux visions de la ville engageons
nous en tant que citoyens dans la
dynamique positive que qu'on voit autour
de nous saisissons nous des problèmes et
créons le grand paris que nous
souhaitons léguer à nos petits enfants
[Applaudissements]